sneo has he left Islam and gone back to
Christianity well he made a tweet what
was the Tweet the Tweet said Christ is
King don't we all get happy when
somebody Embraces Islam how many of us
have the time to dedicate to teaching
them Salah for the first time ever they
are left in the dark without any
guidance you are the reason for people
like Michael like Katrina like Trisha
like me start to pray five times a day
that's f
all due to your donations brothers and
sisters we only need 100 people to
give1 100 can help teach 10 to 30 people
learn how to praise Salah and memorize
Al for the first time ever not only that
these reverts will be teaching their
families their wives their daughters and
their sons to learn how to praise Salah
all because of your donations the
prophet Muhammad s. wasam said when you
die all your Deeds come to an end except
three ongoing charity beneficial
knowledge and a righteous child who
prays for you not only is your donation
an ongoing charity but also an ongoing
beneficial knowledge click the link in
the description below and donate
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends sneo has he left Islam and gone
back to Christianity well he made a TW
tweet what was the Tweet the Tweet said
Christ is King so obviously people are a
bit worried like oh my gosh cuz you hear
that statement from Christians
Christians say Christ is King or Christ
is Lord and Christ is the king of kings
and Christ is ETC what does Christ mean
Christ means the appointed one the
chosen one and we believe he is the
chosen one we believe he's the Messiah
we believe he is the Messiah that will
come and kill the Antichrist the theal
which we believe in so those who are
Muslims should obviously be assuming the
best in their brother it's a basic thing
that Allah says in the Quan inat verse
12 that oh Believers avoid negative
assumptions for indeed some negative
assumptions can be a sin and do not spy
Spy nor backbite one another so it's
very clear that when we hear this kind
of stuff we are told that we assume the
best and that's what we did
alhamdulillah I contacted I am the
Warner just to find out what was the
context of imp posting and just wanted
to understand which angle he was coming
from not that um aldah we doubted him
and that's how it should be we should be
like okay you know what did he mean by
that Etc and obviously we assume the
best like the salaf would do they said
if we saw our brother his beard drenched
in alcohol we'll say somebody put it
over their head if we saw him on a
mountain saying I am your lord and you
are my slave we would assume that he's
reading the verse of the Quran so this
is very important for us to have good
assumptions of our brother he's a Muslim
brother we've spent time with him we
I've done training with him I've done
boxing with him uh we've went an
together a couple of days Etc but still
we see good in him and we see sincerity
in him Subhan Allah yeah and yes that's
what we have to say but so when it comes
to this there's a lot of people have
misconception Christ of course he is the
king how when he comes in his last
coming he's going to be the king yeah
not like a literal King but he is going
to be the one who where there will be
peace he'll be ruling MTH will be
following him and we ask Allah that he
makes us amongst our army we will die
for him that's how much we believe in
him we believe in his miraculous birth
we believe all the Miracles he done we
believe his mother is a righteous person
we do not slander his mother like the
Jews did and start cursing him uh like
the Jews did no we believe in him his
miraculous birth his mother was a
righteous woman not an adul like the
Jewish faith believes in um and we
believe that he's going to come back
he's going to kill the Antichrist yes he
never claimed to be divine he's going to
come and break the cross and kill the
swine why because he's going to kill
Antichrist and Antichrist is going to be
as you guys know a human being a man
walking on Earth making Miracles
claiming to be divine who believes in
that Christians Christians believe in
man can be God and do Miracles that's
why they're going to follow follow the
Antichrist sadly so to our Christian
brothers and sisters watching this we as
Muslims we love Jesus we defend his
honor yes we defend his honor uh as much
as possible and we would love to be in
his army and he is the king of all Kings
on Earth yeah King Kings of all Earth he
is the king of all Kings when he comes
back on Earth he would be when he comes
back okay so we're not talking about the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him uh of
course we know he's the last and final
messeng the best of man to war yeah he's
the subh Allah so I'm talking about when
Jesus comes back he will be the king of
kings okay and we will follow him and he
will be following the Shar of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him so in
that aspect we have no problem with this
and we know he's the Messiah we know
he's the chosen one and we believe in
him and if you think about to look into
the Bible what does it say when Jesus
said and I have many things to say unto
you but you cannot bear them now for he
when the spirit of you shall come he
shall guide you onto all truth he shall
not speak of himself as he hears he
shall speak and he shall glorify me
quick question to our Christian brothers
and sisters yes it says he he he he he
doesn't say spirit Spirit spirit Spirit
oh it says he when the spirit of truth
shall come he shall guide you onto all
truth he shall not speak of himself as
he he should speak uh he shall glorify
me okay so which religion let's put
Hinduism Christ Christianity uh Judaism
sism take all the religions put them to
a side who glorified Jesus and his
mother where there's a whole chapter
about his mother where he is mention and
glorify that no muslim can be a Muslim
if he doesn't believe in him as a
prophet as as a as a individual Subhan
Allah who we love and U will die for who
glorifies him where is this holy spirit
that you're talking about the spirit
here who is it who who has commanded us
to love Jesus no one but Allah subhana
tala through the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him so we are the only religion
that glorify and defend his honor and
his mother and guess what does the
Christians do the Christian Lobby yes
the Zionist Lobby in America they are
eagerly supporting the Jews in Israel
why and it's very ironic actually
they're supporting them because they
believe when Jesus comes he's going to
St to them you know they're just
supporting each other to the dis mayay
that's all have have to say inah so
brother SS assume the best alhamdulillah
there's this tweet going around we know
exactly what he meant there's context
and we assume the best that's it for
myself inah and make Dua for your
brother sneo and many brothers around
Lord who are reever Subhan Allah and
don't forget to that uh the C sisters
and the link below inah that's all I
have to say may Allah bless you guys
look after yourself till next time
alayum have an amazing amazing Ramadan
if you're a new Muslim you want to learn
how to pray Salah go to salah.com AUD
your guided pray and you can book a
Salah instr for absolutely free goodbye